hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from the penultimate
round of the women's European Team
Championship 2023 it is nuro salimova
representing Bulgaria versus Olivia
kobasa representing Poland the battle
happened on board too and it's uh I'm
not going to tell you anything about the
game it's absolutely incredible so let's
just dive straight into it and uh I
would just like to say that salimova is
the only player that went undefeated in
the entire European Women's World Champ
women's European Championship uh and uh
as Bulgaria did win first place that is
that definitely means a lot but both of
them are incredible players both of them
playing um way above their actual rating
here and I believe it's only a matter of
time before they reach 25 2500 and of
course Beyond now let's check it out and
why this game is so incredible I'm not
only showing it because Bulgaria won
first place I'm also showing it as it
features an incredible move that a lot
of you have suggested so let's check it
out uh Nill opens with Pawn to D4 we
have Knight to F6 going for the
so-called Indian Indian game setup where
everything is possible Knight F3 uh the
So-Cal KN Knight's variation of the
Indian and now Pawn to E6 the hor with
defense and now Pawn to C4 basically
transposing into the uh antmo variation
where if white played Knight to C3
instead of Knight to F3 you could just
go for the nimzo Indian you could still
play Bishop to B4 and go uh go for
something that is called the BOGO Indian
defense and while this is all very nice
and I myself enjoy playing it here uh
just Pawn to D5 transposing into the
most popular opening there is with the D
pawn and that is the Queen's Gambit
declined and now you could continue with
Knight to C3 but here we have G3 this is
the Catlin opening and it is a favorite
opening of many many strong players such
as Vladimir kramnik Magnus Carlson well
pretty much everyone plays it and with
great results so here D captures on C4
and Bishop to G2 uh transposing into the
closed Catalin now top moves here are A6
and Knight to C6 Olivia goes for Pawn to
C5 and now castles we have Knight to C6
and Knight to E5 pretty standard move
for a kathin you know that the kathyn
bishop pretty much always Reigns Supreme
the entire game uh Bishop to D7 and now
just Knight captures on C4 well it is
possible to play other moves um uh you
you might be thinking let's uh let's
ruin black pawn structure completely
doesn't really do all that much because
after all the trades captur captur
captur captures captures on D1 Rook
captures here you're going to play
Bishop captures on D5 on C5 uh Knight to
D2 goes after the pawn and once you go
for the Rook here as The Rook is
undefended you will have to move the
Rook let's say Pawn to H5 Knight
captures on C4 and now Pawn to H4 yes uh
uh black is down a PA but black is
controlling the D file black will now
open up the H file and this is a lot of
activity to give up for for the price of
one Pawn so instead after Bishop D7
Knight captures on C4 is the top move
here here we have C captures on D4 and
now Bishop to F4 Bishop to E7 and Knight
to D6 with check King to f8 and now
Knight captures and B7 again all been
played before nothing new here Queen to
B6 we have Knight to D6 and queen to C5
and now uh there are quite a lot of
games actually that reach this position
one of the more famous ones is pet Leo
played against Vladimir kramnik in 2010
where uh the top move recommended by the
engine is played Queen que to B3 and the
queen to B3 although the strongest move
it tends to always end up in a draw
because you just trade everything Bishop
captures and D6 you go for the queen
with Rook to C1 the queen moves and now
you trade Bishop captures and C6 Rook to
C8 pins the bishop but not really Queen
captures on B4 Bishop captures on B4
Bishop captures on D7 Rook captures on
C1 and Bishop captures on C1 and Knight
captures on D7 and after the capture
Fest is over you will get this position
where the material is equal everything
is equal it's an equal game and so Leo
and Kik of course Drew their game and
not here they played it of course but in
the end it ended up in a draw but here
uh nuril goes for Pawn to B4 it's one of
those moves that's possible in every
game you just have to find the perfect
moment to play it and here it um it is
very annoying and very unpleasant for
black now at first it doesn't seem to be
doing all that much but it really is it
is preventing the black queen from
coming to B4 now why is this important
well I will show you Queen captures on
B4 was played A3 and now Queen to C5 and
now uh if you play Queen to B3 as it was
played um in some of the some of the
games between stronger players like
vasak versus Adams um Adan played
against SCH if Queen to B3 then you get
this bishop captures on D6 and Rook to
C1 continues and now it's problematic
because Queen does not have the B4
Square as uh we've seen what happened in
the game between and um and kramnik so
instead after Queen to C5 Knight to D2
was played and now we have Pawn to E5
here again uh if black would be
persistent in capturing the Knight then
Rook to C5 is again very strong because
now after Queen captures on A3 you have
this Knight to C4 move attacking the
queen and the bishop and you're going to
win the bishop or best for black would
be to just give up the queen with Bishop
captures on F4 Knight captures on A3 now
Bishop captures on C1 Queen captures and
Rook to C8 black has some compensation
for the queen uh but after let's say
queen to C5 check black will uh have a
hard time getting that Rook into the
game you can play Rook B1 and the white
will be much much better uh should win
this game uh so instead after Knight to
D2 We have Pawn to E5 and now Knight two
to E4 going after the black queen Knight
captures on e4 Knight captures on e4
attacking the queen once again and the
position has been reached before yes
it's we are still in known Theory uh
Queen to B6 is the move that was played
Samuel Sean played against Jeffrey Shong
in the US Chess Championship 2019 and
the game ended in a draw and indeed
Queen to B6 is the top move recommended
by the engine but here we have Queen to
A5 by Olivia and it is now as of move 17
that we have a completely new game uh so
let's see how uh uh what's the problem
with queen day5 and why it wasn't played
in the game uh Samuel Sean versus
Jeffrey Shong in 2019 well here the
bishop is attacked so you have to move
it you will move it to D2 as it comes
with Tempo this is what nuril goes for
we have Queen back to d8 and now of
course Rook to C1 and if you put the
queen on B6 then of course Rook to B1 if
you put it on C7 then Rook to C1 but Mo
mostly Rook to C1 Rook to C8 and now
Knight to C5 putting pressure on that
bishop and if you allow white to capture
on D7 then this bishop just becomes a
monster and it's like I mentioned in the
beginning of the video If you play the
castling correctly your light Square
Bishop will always be the strongest
piece on the board we have Bishop d8
preserving the bishop pair and now uh
Pawn to F4 uh sort of an engine perfect
way to play it would be Queen to C2
putting immense pressure on this Knight
on C6 uh and um notice you you can't
really move that Knight if you move the
Knight then even some Knight to E6 check
action is possible just picking up the
Rook on C8 so you're going to have to
play something like Queen to C7 but then
comes Queen to E4 and again you will
have an incredibly difficult time
getting getting rid of this spin again
you can't move the Knight because just
knight6 check picks up the queen so it's
an eternal pin that uh I don't know it
it is just very annoying and unpleasant
to play but okay Pawn to F4 was played
and the the king is on f8 she goes for a
more direct approach he wants to open up
the f file and attack the king and now
Pawn to D3 a beautiful move by Olivia
very tricky one freeing up the D the D4
Square for some of the uh Stronger
Black's pieces and the idea is that if e
captures on D3 then she will play Bishop
captures on C5 a move you could pretty
much play in any position up until this
point but it never really does anything
you just give up the bishop pair in
White's position becomes even stronger
but here it would actually work because
it comes with check and after Rook
captures now you have Queen to D4
picking up the Rook on C5 so that's the
idea behind Pawn to D3 so she goes
Knight captures on D3 and now you have
to decide do you give a check first and
then Advance the pawn to E4 where you
will after King to H1 allow nuril to put
the bishop on C3 with Tempo on the queen
and assume this strong diagonal or do
you want to do it uh differently do you
want to sacrifice the E4 Pawn then get
the queen into the game and then capture
the pawn here on A3 she goes for the
other line E4 First bishop captures on
e4 and now Queen to D4 with check now
you have to block with the Knight
otherwise you're going to lose the
bishop on e4 so the Knight here defends
the bishop Bishop captures on A3 now
creating a past a pawn also incredibly
strong uh Rook to C three attack as it
was attacked so you have to move it and
now Bishop to B4 attacking The Rook so
Rook to D3 attacking the queen and queen
to B6 now we have Bishop to E3 attacking
the queen and Bishop to C5 Rook to B3
attacking the queen and now with Queen
to A5 it is still possible to continue
the game however after Knight to B4 the
game is lost and if nural finds the
correct idea she will win this game now
feel free to pause the video and bear in
mind this is only the first pause the
video moment of the video uh second one
is even more difficult so have at
it so uh for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations and spotting
why it is so strong and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is a
rook to C3 Now The undefended Rook on C8
really comes into the picture and uh to
show you why uh let's say let's say you
don't play what Olivia played in the
game let's say we play H6 or H5 it's
it's the strongest recommend
recommendation by the engine the point
is rook ctras and C5 is just so strong
and after rook ctras and C5 you have
this unbreakable pin here you will play
Queen to D2 uh with the idea of bringing
the other Rook into the game and now if
Knight to A6 sort of adding a Defender
to the uh Rook here you will play Rook
A1 with the threat of just capturing the
Knight and then picking up the Rook with
check uh Knight to C7 and now you're
going to play Rook to B1 and the queen
has no squares uh to to defend the Rook
you just have to move it and then you're
going to lose the Rook or you play
Bishop to B5 uh to block The Rook on B1
but then Knight D3 and again you lose
this Rook on C5 if Knight A6 defending
it you will just play Knight captures
and C5 Knight captures and queen to B4
and now finally the game is over so
that's uh that's what happens if you do
nothing here if you just play H6 or H5
which is like I said the strongest
recommended by the engine she played
Bishop captures on E3 she said all right
it's better to give up the exchange than
to lose the game on the spot Rook
captures on C8 and now King to E7
preparing to develop the bishop and get
the other Rook into the game so Queen to
A1 now putting pressure on that G7 pawn
and Bishop to D4 countering the White
Queen Queen to C1 and now we have Pawn
to A5 uh you don't have to worry about
the Rook here it's now defended but now
the past a pawn starts marching forward
and it could be very dangerous as the
bishop covers the queening square so you
have to be fast Rook to C7 check King to
F6 and now Pawn to E3 putting pressure
on the bishop and this is another
beautiful beautiful Pawn sacrifice
Bishop captures on E3 and now Queen to
C3 with check Bishop to D4 and now you
will realize why it was so important uh
feel free to pause the video and win the
game uh for salimova while I give you a
couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on realizing it's
the position from the thumbnail and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Rook to D1 you sacrifice the
queen on C3 for a most uh most uh
intriguing Checkmate and uh it's not
it's not enough to sacrifice the queen
you will also have to sacrifice The Rook
so the idea is that if uh Olivia
captures the queen on C3 then you play
Rook to D6 check and you sacrifice The
Rook as well uh the reason you have to
do this is to take away the D6 Square
from the black king other otherwise the
black king could hide on D6 and Escape
further but now after Queen captures on
D6 you go for Knight to G4 check King to
E6 and F5 is Checkmate as the queen now
prevents the king from uh escaping
further to the queen side I mean uh AB
absolutely stunning Checkmate and uh or
you could end the game like this and
probably Olivia did not want this to
appear on the board but everything else
that she plays also loses the game she
played Knight to C2 to sort of continue
the game but it's just continuing the
game being down a piece yes okay now the
bishop is defended but um just Queen
captures and C2 and you are down
material Bishop captures an F2 check was
played and now King to G2 you could also
capture I mean it's U if if Queen
captures here or if Queen captures on C7
also doesn't matter uh it's the position
is still completely winning as the King
on F6 is uh just in a terrible terrible
spot like Queen to to check all of these
squares are covered you have to go into
position now comes F5 with check King E7
Queen A3 check and uh there's uh not not
much you can do king goes back to to F6
now Rook to D6 with check you either
give up the queen or you go under the
mask of the queen and then you will have
to suffer or you go to G5 and then it's
just a nice mate in three Queen E3
checking to G4 Queen to F4 checking H5
or H3 and then you will just get
checkmated like this or like this or
well whatever you choose so instead
after Bishop captures on F2 King to G2
was played but it doesn't help Bishop to
D4 uh now Rook to C4 and he was in this
position un move 39 that Olivia klasa
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so brilliant
brilliant game by uh by both of them but
even more brilliant by nuril uh I mean
that Queen sacrifice was uh out of this
world and uh I'm very very happy that
you guys suggested me to cover this game
so why you resign well you're just done
material but also aside from that uh
once you as the bishop really has no
squares uh you you can play something
like Bishop D3 but then you go after the
king queen C3 check King to E7 and now a
similar line like we've already shown uh
you don't allow the king to escape King
to E6 now F5 with check King to F6 now
Rook to D6 sorry uh Rook to D6 with
check you're going to win the queen here
captures captures and now it's just
going to be a very quick Checkmate H4
check King to H5 and now any of the
checkmates but Bishop F3 is is the
cleanest and the fastest one uh so yeah
Rook C4 ends the game uh wonderful
performance by nuro salimova the only
undefeated player on team Bulgaria in
the entire European team championship
for nine rounds so uh incredible stuff
she also won a lot of rating let me just
check how much exactly I think she ended
on yeah okay do I think it's on plus 14
as she also has some draws but yeah five
draws and four four four games and those
were from round five to round eight um
all wins in a row so four draws four
wins and then she tops it off with a
draw against Nino B batash in the final
round against Georgia uh but yeah that's
the game hope you enjoyed it uh let's
check out that Queen sacrifice one more
time because I mean when was the last
time you've seen something like this
first the queen sacrifice and then a
rook sacrifice just to prevent the king
from escaping to D6 uh
I mean wow uh but yeah that's the game
thank you for suggesting it hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Derek
King Ahmed El halabi David Gaspar andu
and the desert sand software for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon probably with a game from the
winners of the men's European U team
championship so stay tuned for that uh
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day